So we haven't checked in for a little bit
about what's going on with Corona.
So I want to spend a little time today.
It's been a weekend.
We have another several days of data.
We now have more averages and trends to look
at.
And I want to go a little deeper than just
cases and deaths.
But let's start there.
As of this morning, the United States had
more than 5.2 million confirmed corona virus
cases and just shy of 166 thousand deaths.
Now, remember that in terms of deaths, Donald
Trump said through April and May.
First, he said 15 cases will soon be zero.
That didn't work out in April, May.
Donald Trump said, well, we could end up with
50 or 60000 deaths.
Then it became clear it was gonna be more.
Trump moved the goalpost to seventy eighty
thousand ninety one hundred thousand.
Now it's about keeping it under hundred thousand.
Now, the official death toll at 166.
Later in the show, I'm going to talk to you
about the actual death toll.
Now really is probably more like 225 because
of the uncounted corona virus deaths.
Let me not get ahead of myself.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
But OK.
That were officially at one hundred and sixty
six thousand.
Now, in terms of cases per capita, the states
now at the top of the list are Louisiana,
Arizona, Florida, New York, Mississippi, New
Jersey, Alabama, Georgia, South Carolina,
Rhode Island and Nevada.
And what you're seeing is that what early
in terms of per capita cases were exclusively
these blue state hotspots.
As a result of which states have the direct
flights to the source contagion regions, there's
been a shift to red states, not just in the
total number of cases, but in cases per capita,
because now it's about policy.
Early it was about who had the bad luck or
timing is what I guess I would call it, too,
before we really knew about the virus, have
a lot of direct flights to China and the source
countries in Europe like Italy.
And it was, you know, Boston, New York, New
Jersey area, Chicago, Illinois, the California
airports.
Rhode Island, by virtue of being very close
to Boston, also was hit very hard.
Now it's about who's testing, who has guidelines,
where are people wearing masks, et cetera.
So now it's about policy cases, of course,
depend on tests and how much testing you are
doing.
And as we know, as I told you last week, Florida
and California as examples were under reporting
cases for different reasons.
Florida because of the hurricane.
California for still some unknown reason.
So when you look at one of these examples,
let's look at, for example, Florida, because
of the decreased testing in Florida, Florida
cases started declining in late July, except
we know why they aren't testing as much because
of the hurricane.
But if you look instead of at cases, at hospitalizations,
during the last week, Florida had a record
for single week, new hospitalizations for
Corona virus, just over 30, 300.
That's more than 500 new hospitalizations
per day, including 621 hospitalizations in
Florida last Wednesday.
That's not what you want to see.
And it's another signal of how you can affect
cases by not testing, by changing reporting.
Hospitalizations are a really important indicator.
Now, meanwhile, for political reasons, Donald
Trump is talking about every country now is
seeing a resurgence.
And the reason Trump is doing this is if he
can point to Spain is having a wave to Italy
is having a wave, too.
I guess he thinks that makes the United States
response look less bad.
But there's a few really important things
to think about as we look at some European
countries, see numbers start to climb again.
First of all, we've been expecting a second
wave since March.
This was what doctors thought would happen,
decrease in the summer, back up as we approach
fall in the U.S.
We never even had the gap because when we
got down to 20000 cases per day, most states
started reopening, which is crazy.
Now to the other piece.
Yes.
If you look at some European countries now
like Spain, they are seeing a resurgence in
cases, but they're immediately putting the
guidelines back in place and people are mostly
following them.
So when the president points to we're doing
fine because there are second waves in Europe.
Well, first reaction is we knew and expected
all along that there would be a second wave
in the U.S.
We've been so acutely.
Terrible that we didn't even get a break from
wave one to wave to.
And we're now approaching the fall ourselves.
Secondly, the other countries see the rise.
And they put the guidelines back in place.
Paris is now ramping back up, masking rules
and putting measures back in place.
Trump points to Spain and France to justify
not having taken it seriously.
But the problem with his logic is they didn't
take it seriously and immediately are starting
to right away.
It's completely incoherent, but it's where
we are today and all we can do is deal with
it real quick.
August twenty third is the 15 year anniversary
of The David Pakman Show.
This is a really big deal.
We're on track for a million YouTube subscribers
this year.
Our podcast has grown 40 percent in the last
three months and we're hitting 15 years.
So on the twenty third, we will have a huge,
very special membership special, which you
can be notified of by grabbing a free newsletter
subscription at David Pakman dot com.
This is very exciting.
We're doing something crazy that I may even
regret.
Some governors would probably call the membership
special we're planning illegal and immoral.
I would even say.
But we're going to persevere and do it.
So get on our newsletter at David Pakman dot
com.
August twenty third.
Big, big day in David Pakman show history.
Show at David Pakman dot com.